io noto è partito il menu così perché
gli andava bene bene ragazzi come
multiplayer sisters multiplayer manco
fatto l'altro bene a tutti ragazzi
benvenuti a questo video io so madonna è
brutto io sono fan ejei oggi sensus
troppo facile sia così è una demo vedo
che c'è l'online
ma vedo che gli avversari non esistono
quindi non lo e c'era online man non c'è
rave horror martin garics avversione
slann der meer ciò il telefono e devo
trovare lo spot per il wifi corretto e
qua qua e lo sport eccolo buongiorno
quindi a c'è un codice qr prefetto
connettere network va bene ma funziona
se lo uso aspettativa come prova il
codice quorum adesso funziona davvero se
funziona vero mago è un server dischord
maggiore che figlio
c'è ora impatti
r.bar guccione da pagare ma cos'è
bellissimo 6 la ragazza mette tutto in
modo un po bizzarro di vestirli però ok
c'è anche mike i baschi 6 di gemma l'ha
fatto lei martin garics please sono
salito sulle persone non è proprio il
man salve vuole ballare con me ha una
bella cera stasera lei e non mi sembra
proprio un horror questo ovunque tra
tutti i giochi che ho provato una mia
vita è un live party dove dove vendono
l'acqua minerale eccola qui l'ho cercata
e l'ho trovata signori io devo farvi
degli amici qua comunque se volete
d'avere me lo dite
posso offrirle del buon chianti aveni
che c'è anche il bar e ballano anche i
tipi del bar
a regà statuti imbriaghi cosa devo fare
sto gioco a parte lanciare le bottiglie
dalla gente smettila non gliene frega
niente a lui
due motivi e basta porca vacca ubriachi
di sta cippa svegliate comunque un gioco
incredibile vorrei per un tè la pesca
mia zia e le sta punte alla pesca mia
madre è un esca un tè alla pesca
maledizione non riesco neanche a
prendere lo prendo da solo
mortacci vostri coordinate a ballare a
farli cari vostri tester i dvd niente
vestrini cos'è guarda poveristi degli
occhi stanno guardando beh penso proprio
di sì niente scandalizziamo il codice qr
a questo punto c'è un buon codice coar
usiamo dopo cos'è sta roba
siamo tutti nello stesso gruppo di
whatsapp cosa faccio e joey de paris
benvenuto al festival senza testa dove
l'amore e il vino volano jade parti è
iniziato sono pronto a tutti stanno
seguendo questa cosa e poi iniziano a
ballare insieme a ragazzi potreste anche
divertirvi senza sembrare in crisi
epilettica lo sapete tempeste cas
progressing end of action fa john e
madonna mitico queste cuffie non c'hanno
il cavo e le perdo baldo dove ci sono le
croci al contrario me ne voglio andare
via via dalle parti via dalle parti
basta per 75 singers in tuffo
vuol dire dedalus dance for the dance
kids mila il film sto andando
chissenefrega
porca voce qualcuno qui mi scusi ah no
c'è un altro codice ma come c'è un'altra
porta lan o che figata
ho aperto un'altra cevo scriverti
qualcosa ma ci sembra qualcosa
salve ho pure cavalca mi sono cagato
sotto
questo mia corsa non pensavo la morte da
solo va bene che sono risvegliato
ubriaco in mezzo
mi sono risvegliato ubriaco in mezzo
alla dance for va bene c'è qualcosa
salve mi scusi cos'è che state facendo
ho capito è un due tre stella
adesso che si gira e the cell fermino
c'è un tizio che cammina ma è proprio un
gioco cristiano web salve cosa fa ma lo
sa che qui non c'è musica sta ballando a
vuoto e io le posso mettere qualsiasi
musica di sottofondo sembrerebbe un
imbecille è nato povero è cresciuto
povero è morto povero checa che detto da
fare
e vabbè non so cosa sto vedendo ma non
fa niente andiamo avanti ragazzi sempre
comunque bello scoprire che c'è qualcosa
qua sempre per il telefono proviamo tira
fuori tira fuori il telefonino
telefonino
eccolo dance kimi live just be devo
praticamente metterli come sono qua va
bene però da che parte si guarda questa
cosa mi scusi la smette di muoversi come
un ossesso qua allora come da che parte
si guarda questa cosa non capisco da che
parte lo guardo ma immaginiamo devo
trovare il punto davanti appunto dietro
penso che da dove è rivolto il tizio
penso sia quello dal tizio rivolto di
qua questo mezzo è una faccina quindi
teoricamente un pugno essi infatti sono
cinque quindi 115 allora questo qua deve
essere messo tipo questo quadro e da bar
e deve da ballo sperano posso tenere il
telefono aperto mentre lo faccio fare no
daba daba usa file adobe in qualche modo
provaci bravo va bene allora questo qua
invece tutte e due le mani così si sa
come no
o o frate non ho fatto niente o sei
brutto come veramente madonna non mi
toccare brut ma se ti si drogava sono
cavoli tuoi
ma cosa è successo
ma cosa ho fatto
ok io non ho io gli avevo fatto niente
da te possino non ho fatto
se ti sei bevuto delle robe che ti hanno
drogati colpa tua cavoli tuoi basta
basta non c'è drogato punto saragat e
via tutti va bene così sarò là per terra
qua no non lo voglio qui non lo voglio
ho trovato una pietra di brutta ma cosa
devo farmi egli sta roba è bella però
complimenti e un bel pezzo di mobilio
volendo posso metterla me la metto nel
rapporto alla festa la porta la festa la
butto all'arancio al dj la sento la vedo
ci siamo ci siamo perfetto si vede si
sente c'è solo è qui presente non
capisco dove sta succedendo to the fai
il rito ma poco è successo qua tutto
bene è quante volte ne vedo di scene
così in discoteca ragazzi cosa è
successo qua entrato mammut ha tirato
testate a tutti contesto parla cosa è
successo qua sono entrato nel grande
cancello sono attraverso la foresta devo
finire il rito credo sia questo c'è un
negozio di televisori di scena storie
ragazzi in quanti bong ti sei fatto tu
creatore visto gioco c'è una maschera o
e successo a me mi scusi sa un po la
pelle d'oca lei non mi piace
no no no non mi piace quella roba lì non
mi piace infilate la tu ma porca vacca
porca no ma hanno drogato niente ragazzo
finito così sono finito così ma cosa lui
ti fai schifo
cosa scatta un altro gatto tizio è
scappato va bene e succede purtroppo
tutto bene a posto io sto bene il mio
telefono se neanche mi è arrivato pure
il telefono pezzente proprio devi
seguire il team mi ha rubato il telefono
polizia
fate qualcosa porca put a raqqa porca
sto bene sto bene sono solo drogato
buongiorno dopo bisogno mi scusi ma gè
rubat
bello il suo telefono ci avevo un
telefono una volta io però me l'hanno
rubato è la storia in parti qua stai in
the light is here bisogno di ri nasce un
braccio qui e io ti rubo il braccio così
siamo pari
un braccio venute apposta in the light e
io ce l'ho all'élite è satana qui credo
una medusa attaccata all'albero va bene
tutto a posto sto bene sto bene tutto
bene tutto bene sento solo dei rutti
fortissimi non spegnere non spegnere non
spegnere ben aiuto solo nelle luci sono
delle luci fai il rito ma basta questo
rito a devo fare il dj
scusate c'è una ghigliottina lì ma io
non devo mettere la testa qua dentro
ma infila celato ci infilo il mio caso
stato mista vibrando il telefono che non
ho al ha messo lì dentro ball maledetto
quello che mi ha rubato il telefono l'ha
messo qua e devo prendere il telefono
premio premio fa niente se c'è la
ghigliottina tanto non può farlo ma come
thank you for dying ma cosa vado fuori a
solda no other hand and for those who
conclude ricci
c'è un altro finale a questo quindi era
il finale va bene grazie per essere
morto nella nostra fare strada prego e
stata una bella avventura comunque vi
ringrazio per aver fatto questo
bellissimo però inisieme cento ragazzi
iscritti al canale schiacciate il tasto
mi piace che trovate vicino ma al tasso
iscritti che matt e importante lasciato
un bel commento se cosa ne pensate di
questo gioco perché per me ciao
[Musica]